the other thing that i was telling you
before was the the caller daddy thing
yep and oh yeah you said you were
responsible yeah
this is how okay
i was supposed to go on a date with
sophia yeah with an f with an f in case
you didn't know uh yeah no i know and i
had to
i played in a basketball game i think or
something i was like exhausted so i i
hit her up and i was like hey can we
reschedule yeah
and she was uh upset and she was like
i'm gonna go on a date with somebody
tonight superman was who she went with
interesting small world
yeah i don't know i i'm sorry man yeah
no i listen
that was gonna end probably poorly no
matter what ended up probably been good
because they were left anyways right and
the controversy that ensued because of
that yeah probably ended up helping us a
little bit you think you got a little
bit yeah you thrive in the well it's
like
so caller daddy when that debate was
going on it's caller daddy kind of and
we let people do whatever they want at
barcelo so a lot of the caller daddy
crowd as i was growing really didn't
know who i was or barstool they were
just do they were caller daddy fans and
and if they left as they were planning
to leave it would have been a he said
she said and people would believe her
their crowd would believe them
that they're not even listening to you
correct yeah but when they got in that
dispute
they just stopped podcasting they didn't
put out an episode for two months put
out something and then their feet took
their feed and i went
all these girls
there wasn't a new one there was all
these rumors and it's like two months
there hasn't been an episode and then
suddenly on a fee it's like uh new
caller daddy is just [ __ ] me for like
45 minutes
here's what's going on um so yeah it
probably helped we got a lot of new fans
and most people whether you like me or
don't like
i come across as credible it's like he's
he's telling the truth he's willing to
talk he's not like even when you ask it
or anything i won't talk about i'll talk
about anything there's no skeletons well
there are skeletons while talking about
them so it's uh it probably worked in
our favor